am abend des 11
juli 1981 fertig gymnasiastin annika
hutter mit dem mofa nach winterthur und
freunde zu treffen
sie kommt nie an in die serie polizei
ist ein jüngerer mann mit mofa und
anhänger darin soll die 18 jährige
annika zuletzt gesehen worden sein
was dann geschieht ist unklar
annika hutter bleibt spurlos
verschwunden
für die familie eine katastrophe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das haben wir doch gar nicht schilder
steuerabgaben der fall annika hutter
gibt der polizei und der justiz rätsel
auf es gibt keine spuren kein opfer und
keine täter
das ist einfach irgendwie im fall nicht
abgeschlossen ist einfach ein fall wo
man einfach sagt man eigentlich nicht
auf eure widersacher will irgendwie hat
das auge für familie für gesellschaft
für strafrecht im speziellen und sie
muss man irgendwie noch viele da muss
man irgendwie ihrem analytiker und
zeigst dass man einfach nur weiß was
wirklich passiert ist
[Musik]
das heißt vor der letzten fort ich sehe
ja einige von ihnen lieblingsfoto
geschick sind war unser futter ist der
vater der verschwundenen annika vor
seiner pensionierung leitete er mehrere
restaurants in seiner erinnerung war
annika immer ein problemloses kind sie
ist krank sie nie sie hat mir gefällt
diese schule
sie hätte aber trotz phase kam kann mich
nicht mehr erinnern aber klar ich das
jetzt sage glorifizieren
aber sie ist effektives achim sie
zuverlässig mit sich ein psychologisch
sehr rief sicheres alter ja
annika ist beliebt und zielstrebig zur
zeit ihres verschwindens steckt sie
mitten in den maturitätsprüfungen später
will sie agronomie studieren bilder aus
glücklichen tagen
der vater mit den beiden töchtern vor
dem 11 juli 1981 sind und dass eine
harmonische familie kleinkind annika mit
ihrer mutter eva mutter ist gebürtige
schwedin weltoffen lebensfroh und ganz
für die familie da die drei jahre
jüngere corinne liebt annika über alles
über den verlust der schwester kommt sie
nie hinweg genau wie mutter eva diese
stirbt kurz vor den dreharbeiten nach
einer schweren krankheit rückkehr an den
ort wo annika vor 25 jahren verschwand
mit jedem schritt kommen auch die
emotionen von damals zurück
immer noch fühlt sich josef mutter
seiner tochter hier am nächsten
für mich wenn ich doch erinnere mich
genau wie das kind am tag
[Applaus]
und hier viele viele male boni und wohl
mehr sport
es hätte bis
[Applaus]
sehr bequemen aber ich immer das sind
alles beim sie große ballen
es ist also abschnitt xi abgeschlossen
[Applaus]
erinnerungen werden wach an den
verzweifelten anruf seiner frau eva am
sonntagmorgen dem 12 juli 81 annika
wollte den vorabend in winterthur mit
klassenkollegen verbringen am sonntag
morgen kehrt sich jedoch nicht wie
vereinbart nach müngersdorf zurück
telefoniert also mini vgh geschafft und
dan hacker kabelanbietern exakt gar
nicht verschwunden
wenn man sofort eine anzeige machen und
wenn sie im winter durch polizei und
sind denn selber mit der klasse kamera
die themen bosniens dorf winterthur
übersteigt unter ohne über kempten
absurd rede einig sie schnell gefahren
und hätten unfall kam die familie
freunde und schulkameraden machen sich
auf annika zu suchen
den ganzen nachmittag durchforsten sie
die umgebung ihres wohnortes nixdorf
am späteren nachmittag finden sie
annikas mofa
genau das sie am rand dieses gestanden
ich sehe es wie wenn es gestern
sie wissen dass dort abgestellt
auf dem ständer ist auf dem ständer ganz
genau weiß was ich selber paket oder
wer hat das mofa hier abgestellt was ist
dann geschehen dieses mofa hier auf
einem foto der kantonspolizei zürich
sollte bis heute der einzige konkrete
hinweis auf annika bleiben
die kriminaltechnische untersuchung
ergibt dass die 18 jährige wegen einer
technischen panne anhalten musste
in der nacht von samstag auf sonntag
regnet es heftig für die polizei ein
problem denn sämtliche spuren werden
verwischt
[Applaus]
die polizei die vor ort ermittelt findet
keine hinweise die auf ein gewaltdelikt
schließen lassen
peter weber fahnder für
kapitalverbrechen bei der kantonspolizei
zürich erinnert sich am boden oder
süßstoff ist das ist wie es obwohl
bereits wiederholt das waldstück rund um
den fundort des mofas wird von der
polizei systematisch durchkämmt auch
josef hutter beteiligt sich an der suche
abends um acht es ist noch hell wird die
aktion ergebnislos abgebrochen
ein schlimmer moment für den vater
was mich denn
eigentlich schockiert hat wurde leighton
die die polizei
so mahne gebrechlich und dem von selber
wieder zum waldes und das hat mir ich
bin nicht zurück stand ist ich gehe und
es hat mit den eigentlich die ganze zeit
verfolgt die österreich zum ersten mal
ernst der vater dass er annika nie
gesehen wird
die polizei gelangt an die medien und
erhofft sich so hinweise aus der
öffentlichkeit
regor fust arbeitete über 30 jahre für
die boulevard zeitung blick
jahrelang hat in der fall annika
beschäftigt als die polizei das
kommuniqué herausgibt geht es sofort bei
familie oder vorbei vorstellt
und dankt wie das ist doch schon den
rücktritt elf aufbieten
der polizeilich erfahren
die mithelfen
sie sind natürlich unter schock sie sich
wie wahre männer niemals land sie wie
oder wie man doch sie hat zwar viel geld
aber irgendwie die lage ist so
angespannt mehr ist es nicht und es
kommen einfach denkt irgendwann und
irgendwie wird in bewegung setzte greco
fuß trifft eine gute geschichte über
monate schreibt der unzählige artikel
über annikas verschwinden
[Musik]
so ist es dann so dass ich praktisch die
ihr geschäft über no hand und wieder
kontakt mit der familie und polizei mit
der umgebung noch ein recherchieren und
es ist für mich eine vor der größten
geschäfte gesehen wo nicht in rom zurück
machten inzwischen laufen die
ermittlungen der polizei auf hochtouren
eine großfahndung läuft an
sie hat unzählige suchaktionen macht
mehr hat
helikopter das gebiet nur grob abgesucht
proben habe ich natürlich nur bedingt
brauchbar wenn man die gebiete bruder
durfte hat ist vielleicht trifft zeigen
nur rohstoff lindau standortstruktur man
hat abgesucht weil ich früh wach so
funky kanalisation hat überprüft merkt
gebäude im wiederum reis überprüft laut
stehen die gebäude ökonomiegebäude
verbuchen so und er hat auch mit aktion
auch mit hundeführer zum teil sind es
über 20
die gebiet abgesucht haben mehrere
zeugen melden sich
sie wollen am samstagabend zwischen 19
und 20 uhr bei kemptal eine merkwürdige
szene beobachtet haben ein mann mit
einem mofa aber in einem anhänger eine
junge frau transportiert
[Musik]
die polizei geht von einer entführung
aus junge frau die mit sisi mit dem
größten oberkörper alexander hat sie
sofort fordert blick die lisa zur
mithilfe auf
[Musik]
in zürich liegen neben diesen hinweisen
aber auch noch liegt auch noch eine
dringende warnung vor bitte konrad enz
wie schon angekündigt wollen wir noch
einmal auf den entführungsfall annika
hutter zurückkommen auch die
fernsehsendung aktenzeichen xy ungelöst
sucht mit die 18 jährige gymnasiastin
ist wie bekannt am 11 juli 1981 auf dem
weg von ihrem wohnort nirgends dorf nach
winter durch entführt worden und zwar in
einem recht ungewöhnlichen fahrzeug
inzwischen besitzt die polizei auch eine
etwas genauere beschreibung vom täter er
ist etwa 30 jahre alt mittelgroß schlank
bis mittlere statur hat aus der braune
haare und machte einen ungepflegten
eindruck
die sendung aktenzeichen xy löst beim
blick einen ansturm auf die eigens dafür
eingerichteten blick telefone aus dazu
beigetragen hat wohl auch die belohnungs
summe von 10000 franken telefon das
alles aufgeschrieben und die sache mit 1
alles zur weiterbearbeitung polizei alle
hinweise führen ins leere
die öffentliche aufmerksamkeit wird für
hutters zum alptraum
sie werden von anonymen anrufen
belästigt was suchen oder sind innenhof
sache passiert trittbrettfahrer lüth wo
sich handle
im vordergrund stellen pendler hält sich
volvo und sichert wüssten wo man da
nicht gewillt war sega wo das genau
gesehen etwas abgegangen ist und deutsch
also riesensache bistum mehr sind auch
mit dem telefon terrorisiert worden
tag und nacht vor der unmöglich stelle
mittlerweile geht der blick journalist
bei der familie ein und aus mehr über
annikas verbleib zu erfahren
fährt gregor fust gar nach holland zu
einem bekannten wahrsager ich habe ist
in holland und die sind ganz bekommt die
limousine des akkus goldige bluttests
karnevalistische alles gemacht dem
alfred sonders problem die dann auch
noch schnell auf 1 rede nach holland
aber brauchen aber mit dem gerät und er
hat wie die meisten einfach auf see
starkstrom bleibt die geballte macht der
umgebung die fotos zur kenntnis genommen
bitten
hey zu hause bei familie oder in hörens
dorf herrscht verzweiflung
mutter und tochter nehmen medikamente um
die angst und die anonymen anrufe zu
ertragen sogar presse haben sich
gemeldet wie mir stoke city der
furchtbare situation noch mit erpresse
vor geld in neues größeres unglück
stürzt oder das sind schlimme mia farrow
xii
und doch ist mit jedem anruf die
hoffnung auf ein lebenszeichen der
verschwundenen annika verbunden
familie mutter ist in dieser schwierigen
zeit ganz auf sich gestellt
professionelle opferhilfe gibt es in den
80er jahren in der schweiz noch keine
jeder muss das unfassbare allein
verarbeiten
[Musik]
kein psychologe oder irgendwo ist
kümmert wir sind also mit mit diesem
problem der durch yoga nyc sie polizei
die haftung der mit und gemacht aber
heute 25 jahre später ist opferhilfe ein
wichtiger bestandteil der polizeiarbeit
als professor für strafrecht doziert
daniel jositsch an der universität
zürich über täter und opfer erschien zum
3 1 ins kies opferhilfe gesetz
geschaffen wurde und mit dem opfer hilfe
gesetz ist dazu holt das opfer und
opferfamilie position hat im
strafverfahren
sie wirkte mit sie habe nach dem
verfahren sich mit dem verteidiger über
sie wertet berater und sie haben die
entschädigungsansprüche das ist aber
damals war der fall laut passiert sich
einig dass sie das leben muss irgendwie
weitergehen
josef hutter hilft seiner arbeit in der
gastronomie
aber in jeder freien minute denkt er an
seine verschwundene tochter und streift
durch die wälder der umgebung
[Musik]
bis hundertmal der user vor und hat auch
die fall nur gerührt man mal im internet
doch ihr handy möglich sei was sind oder
um die hätten so kind das beim könnte
[Musik]
ein
in der familie denn sehr großes problem
gefühlsmäßig und und einfach wie
mit dem täglichen leben wir sind wie
takko und das ist es mehrere schwierige
situation sie um wir sind zu sehr auf
uns eingestellt und für meine familie
für mich ist es keine ich betrachte
absorbiert sie haben oft haben es meine
frau ist vielfacher leide heicks
animation räder tochter
und
er hätte eigentlich gar nicht realisiert
was also abgegangen ist dass ich den er
später vor dass das menü sehr große
probleme hat und auch meine tochter hat
sehr viel problem kam
familie mutter zieht sich zurück
[Musik]
nicht nur die betroffenen sind
überfordert der chefarzt des
psychologisch psychiatrischen dienstes
des kantons zürich frank urbaniok
beobachtet dass auch freunde und
bekannte nicht wissen wie sie in einer
solchen situation reagieren sollen
diese unsicherheit führt dazu dass sich
viele von opferfamilien abwenden es gibt
reaktionen oft in der frühphase einer
solchen straftat dass es mit leid gibt
von der umgebung dass man viel
verständnis hat das erschöpft sich aber
häufig nach einigen wochen oder monaten
und dann findet man nicht selten eine
distanzierung des umfeldes von dem opfer
das opfer symbolisiert weiter die
ohnmacht das erlebnis die trauer und es
gibt durchaus psychologisch gesehen eine
hemmung sich mit dieser trauer dieser
ohnmacht weiter auseinander zu setzen
man will damit gar nicht so viel zu tun
haben und dann sieht man tendenzen vom
umfeld entweder des rückzugs oder dass
man sagt jetzt muss irgendwann mal genug
sein mit der trauer man kann ja nicht
ewig trauern als kommt so distanz
bewegungen die letztlich dazu führen
dass opfer langfristig alleine bleiben
opferfamilien die hooters gibt es viele
in den 80er jahren
denn in dieser zeit verschwinden
zahlreiche kinder
zumeist wurden sie opfer von
serientätern einige von ihnen werden tot
aufgefunden
von anderen gibt es bis heute keine spur
rebecca bieri verschwindet 1982 loredana
mancini 1983 im selben jahr wie benjamin
ecke
darauf wird peter roth vermisst 1985
verschwindet daniel sutter
[Musik]
edith rickenbachs 1986 dann christian
widmer 87 fabian imhof verschwindet 1989
das gleiche schicksal erleidet auch die
sechsjährige sarah opfer song 1985 sucht
die ganze schweiz fieberhaft nach diesem
verschwundenen kind in ihrem wohnort
sachs soll im kanton wallis will die
kleine sarah an einem septembertag zur
großmutter in der nachbarschaft am abend
findet man nur noch ihr fahrrad beim
schulhaus das ganze dorf hilft bei der
suche mit ohne erfolg die polizei geht
hinweisen bis nach buenos aires nach 100
tausend flugblätter werden weltweit
verteilt die eltern appellieren
wiederholt an den täter
sechs jahre später schildert sarahs
mutter ihre gefühle
sie ähneln jenen von annikas mutter
trotz allem behalten wir die hoffnung
das schwierigste ist die unsicherheit
die ist sehr schmerzhaft
es gibt tage wo man optimistischer ist
und tage wo man wenig hoffnung hat
trotzdem überwiegt am schluss immer die
hoffnung 21 jahre ist es her seit sarah
verschwunden ist
wurde sie entführt und an ein
kinderloses paar verkauft oder ermordet
niemand kennt die antwort der fall sarah
obersee ist verjährt dennoch geht die
strafverfolgungsbehörde im märz 2006
einem neuen hinweis nach
vor kurzem erklärte ein zeuge an dieser
stelle in aurélio im tessin vor 20
jahren ein frisches grab entdeckt zu
haben das von sarah die aktion verläuft
ergebnislos wie alle anderen
inzwischen vergeht im fall annika zeit
monate und jahre später hat die polizei
noch immer nichts vorzuweisen
utopien zwar in nürensdorf nachbar der
familie mutter als polizist und
ehemaliger schulkollege des vaters
wollte er helfen und die ermittlungen
vorantreiben
nach annikas verschwinden name in der
damaligen wohnung hutters fingerabdrücke
die helfen sollten annika zu
identifizieren
falls man sie gefunden hätte im
ehemaligen zimmer von annikas schwester
entdeckte er damals die zeichnung die
kuren in ihrer trauer vor 25 jahren in
die fensterscheibe eingesetzt hat
koblenz hat aus eigener initiative
recherchiert bis heute glaubt felsenfest
an seine these von zwei tätern überzogen
das dkb dem waldstück vergewaltigt wurde
nicht derzeit weiterer kleider von lieb
chris hat sich verletzt
aber das ist nicht der täter
wo sie nach einer abtransportiert hat
die mauer hängen
das ist eine zweite person und darum bin
ich einfach überzogen
das thema wo sie an transportiert hat
der michael helfen die anne kann muss
dann aber auf dem weg in rom 8 falle sie
und dan ist zweifellos thema mit
anhänger in panik eine karte und in der
panik in hätte er denn das mittel der
richtlinie verpackt und ich wegfahren
anschließend habe er sie umgebracht ist
annika zwei verschiedenen tätern in die
hände gefallen
nur eine von unzähligen spekulationen
das geständnis eines mannes ein jahr
nach annikas verschwinden lässt hoffen
dieser 23 jährige behauptet zwei frauen
umgebracht zu haben
eine davon sei annika hutter gewesen in
der untersuchungshaft zieht er jedoch
die geständnisse zurück
ermittlungsfehler der polizei machen
seinen fall zum justizskandal
der verdächtige wird freigesprochen 15
jahre nach dem 11 juli 81 ließ die
familie annika für verschollen erklären
dass man den tätern überführte ist für
alle schwer zu ertragen
und so will informationen das nicht
gelöst wurde ich dass das ich mehr
hütten ausreizen panik warum nicht warum
ein fall für den sonderstaatsanwalt pius
schmid
er ist der einzige sonderstaatsanwalt
der schweiz und ermittelt ausschließlich
in ungeklärten tötungsdelikten des
kantons zürich die viele jahre
zurückliegen
annika hutter fall gehört zu den
aufwendigeren in der schweizer
kriminalgeschichte
sie sind einfach wieder für gezielt die
löhne verhandeln
es gibt viele viele jahre zwischen sie
findet viele auskunftspersonen
unternehmen spricht
und das macht es auch relativ
kompliziert und schwer
trotz aller schwierigkeiten konzentriert
sich pius schmid auf einen verdächtigen
sieben jahre nach annikas verschwinden
behauptet ein bereits inhaftierte
straftäter
er habe annika getötet und braucht im
kampf und sexuelle missbrauch sexuell
und wo sich kreativ sie umgebracht
das geständnis hat er am nächsten tag
bereits wieder hoffen
der mann wurde wegen wiederholten mordes
zu einer lebenslangen zuchthausstrafe
verurteilt
er gilt als gemeingefährlich und nicht
therapierbar
mit einer entlassung in die freiheit ist
nicht zu rechnen
sonderstaatsanwalt pius schmid ist
überzeugt dass dieser mann annikas
mörder ist wieviel schmid zweifelt auch
psychiater frank urbaniok nicht dass das
einmalige geständnis eines solchen täter
typus der wahrheit entsprechen dürfte
personen die insgesamt mehr erfahrung
der justiz haben oder die eine die nicht
so beeindruckt war sind von ihren
gefühlen her bei denen ist es eher
wahrscheinlich dass ein einmaliges
geständnis das widerrufen wird er der
durchbruch der wahrheit war der dann
wieder in der normalform wieder
zurückgenommen wird wir sind immer noch
zimmer trage vor wie der beweismittel
und anhaltspunkt und indizien wo mir
anhöre der laube auch urheberrechte
betreffen die akten über den fall annika
hutter liegen also noch ganz oben beim
sonderstaatsanwalt allerdings geht er im
sommer in pension
ein staatsanwalt der seit jahren mit dem
fall betraut ist ermittelt weiter war
mal aus versucht hat vermittler als
mögliche zeugen befragt hat und nicht
wieder ist dann ist man oft berühmte
kommissar zufall lichthof krise das
derzeit völlig gleich los geständnis
macht mögliche wie's geht griechen und
spuren wo man mit modernen
ermittlungsmethoden nochmals werte
möglicherweise hat das ich habe an ein
anderer personen auf droht wo dann will
ich irgendwann beiseite es wichtig ist
aus dem topf gibt und immer dran bleibt
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man so
einen fall ohne dass der täter das will
noch ein aufklärer ist natürlich schlimm
nach dem verlust von annika gehörten
unbeschwerte momente bei eva und josef
hutter der vergangenheit an
nach einigen jahren brachte ehe
auseinander weiß es eigentlich hätten
die sich einfach mini version für meine
frau ist jedes männliche messe
eigentlichen täter sie in irgendwelcher
art und das hätte ihres gefühls lebe so
stark verändert dass sie es einfach mit
- kalte hätten andere natur bin ich habe
wieder lebe ich bkk ich hatte mein name
ist stelle ich eine platzkarte besonders
und das hat mir natürlich auch bei
anderen sieht es sehr viel käufe sie
hätt's auch nicht verteilt dass sich
widerhaken im fernsehen ein fußballmatch
loacker und und um mich begeistert ich
glaube jetzt einfach für mich ist damit
eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig wie der
schmerz für mich genauso großvater starb
in diesem frühling an den folgen ihrer
langjährigen krankheit in der
todesanzeige ist zu lesen dass sie nun
wieder mit ihrer geliebten annika verein
sein
ja das ist einfach emotional immer so
sagt er begegnet sich wieder und mit
glaubitz natürlich so dass musik
gestorben ist dass sie der alpha beta
oder in der ewigkeit und dass sie jetzt
gefunden hat das glauben was so
verstrahlt
annika sei nie vergessen werden allein
deswegen hat josef hutter in diesem film
mitgemacht
für seine tochter die verschwunden ist
und ihn doch immer begleitet
[Musik]